buenos días estamos exactamente en el
lugar que ayer estaba lleno de gente en
una jornada maratoniana que comenzó a
las 10 de la mañana y se extendió hasta
las 12 de la noche o más donde seguía
habiendo gente en este mismo lugar las
autoridades dieron hoy un balance hay
580 detenidos en todo el país
287 de ellos en la región metropolitana
donde nos encontramos un total de 107
actos o incidentes violentos también el
subsecretario de interior juan galli
confirmó la muerte de una persona en la
población de la victoria en hechos que
aún se investigan si tendría que ver el
actuar de carabineros en esa situación
ahora dos iglesias fueron quemadas por
encapuchados en el centro de la capital
chilena le pregunto si se sabe por qué
lo hicieron
bueno esa es la pregunta un poco del
millón pero es cierto que las iglesias
han sido objeto de ataque durante el
estallido social en varias ocasiones de
hecho las dos iglesias habían sido
atacadas se trata de la iglesia de
carabineros que ya había sido una
iglesia que pertenece a la institución a
la policía chilena ya había sido quemada
en enero de este mismo año y también la
iglesia cuya cúpula cayó la iglesia de
la asunción que se encuentra a escasos
metros de donde nos encontramos ahora
también había sido vandalizada es verdad
que en el país existe mucha rabia contra
los escándalos de pedofilia que hicieron
los titulares mundiales hace unos años y
que es un también un icono un reflejo de
un poder estatal y también se suele
atacar contra este tipo de institución o
con este tipo de contra las iglesias que
han sido objeto de ataques vandálicos en
el país se registraron también saqueos y
otros incidentes violentos